lifeguards are not the only people
looking out for your safety along fan
its coastline but we are the guys and
girls you'll see most when you're on the
beach in the summer maritime and
coastguard agency i work alongside the
lifeguards and although you won't see us
as often as the lifeguards we're
constantly watching the coast to keep
you safe
Her Majesty's Coast Guard was
established hundreds of years ago but
for a very different reason they're
established a combat smuggling something
that was rifle on math anak coast in the
18th century boy although smuggling
still goes on today the Coast Guard is
now committed to preventing loss of life
at sea fan it's Coast Guard Station is
based right here on the cliff top of
Palm Bay this is the home of the margate
Coast Guard team and the base for all
our rescue equipment the station opened
in 2006 and covers the area from the
culvert hours to the north side of the
river stour did you know that has been a
Coast Guard presence on the art of fanuc
since records began margate Coast Guard
rescue team is one of the busiest teams
in the southeast sometimes dealing with
over a hundred Coast related incidents
each year another organization that
looks after our safety along the coast
is the royal national lifeboat institute
or the RN alive for sure the RNLI works
very closely with the Coast Guard when
there's an incident at sea many people
confuse the Coast Guard the live gods
and the RNLI and this is probably
because we work so closely together when
you dial 999 and ask for the Coast Guard
it's the Coast Guard who takes the call
and coordinates the rescue they then
pass the information on to the nearest
suitable R&R lifeboat station who
launches the boat
to help whoever's in trouble there are
two are analyzed stations in thanet one
is located in margate in the harbor um
car park and the other is located in
ramsgate harbor it is usually the are
analyzed lifeboats you will see speeding
along coast
I and the Coast Guard operate 24 hours a
day 365 days of the year and depend upon
brave volunteers to crew the boats and
save lives at sea even regardless of the
weather an important difference is that
lifeguards on fan its beaches only
operate during the day in your school
holidays from May until sep tember this
is something that you will need to
remember the life guards will not always
be around when there's an incident on
the beach so what do you do if someone
is in trouble that's right they've got
it make sure you remember that too